there's a more harmonious tone as allies
meet for the first time since the
pandemic struck
it's a contrast to the discord brought
by donald trump
his successor now rebuilding relations
and rebooting the alliance nato stands
together
that's how we've met every other threat
in the past
it's our greatest strength as we meet
our challenges
of the future and there are many a key
one is russia
with joe biden off to meet vladimir
putin on wednesday
for the first time as president i'm
going to make clear
to president putin that
there are areas where we can't cooperate
if he chooses
and if he chooses not to cooperate
and acts in a way that he has in the
past
relative to cyber security and some
other
activities then we will respond
he's bright he's tough
and uh i have found that uh he is a uh
as they say when he used to play ball a
worthy adversary
seeking to strengthen nato from all
threats allies agreed on plans for the
future
they sounded more ambitious than
anything attempted under the previous
u.s administration
they pledged for the first time to
combat the impact of climate change
and agreed that china presents systemic
challenges to international rules and
values
allies meeting here appear relieved that
donald trump is no longer in the room
but the challenge he posed to nato pales
into insignificance
compared with the one posed not just by
russia but also
by an increasingly assertive china and
by the different ways countries can hurt
each other
from cyber attacks and fake news to
launching
super-fast missiles and even targeting
satellites in space
in fact hostile action in space could
prompt
nato to retaliate just as it would to a
more conventional ground attack
we will make it clear at this summit
that of course any attack
on space capabilities like satellites
and so on
or attacks from space will
could trigger article 5.
that's in a way just to clarify
something which has been
in many ways obvious for a long time
it's also increasingly obvious the
alliance has a huge amount of work to do
to deliver its goals
and counter this unprecedented array of
new threats
debra haynes sky news brussels